non pas musulmane est-ce que vous
condamnez
le match en annonçant qu'on a enduré par
les médias france voulait que les
messages n'ont jamais parlé mais j'aime
la pression elle vraiment des années
elle est ce que les poupées sur sa
nation et son visage je suis venu pour
parler de dieu qui
coupait sympa de le lire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sourit myriam palombes à hilla nathalie
marqué il a ça s'arrange entre eux
ça va mieux ça va mieux détiennent a
comparé voir là une voie là de la
famille et tes colères laissé un mot sur
facebook sur cette affaire j'en ai tant
la suite les parents quand c'est pas moi
si c'est france dimanche voilà même
principe en phase i sur le scoop
ils sont alors j'ai gala ou paris match
vous vous exposez votre vie privée c'est
un choix parce que les photos sont
belles fait rêver les gens tous les
jours heureux vais vous faire pour ces
huit on se donne parce que c'est très
bien nager vasily la meilleure forme et
agents que ses positions et qui donne du
plaisir aux gens mais là franchement je
ne vois pas ce qui fait plaisir aux gens
quand j'envoie ce titre la paire vous
n'êtes pas l'hépatite moi je vous dis
j'ai reçu les gens les gens connaissent
que très bien le magazine il existe
depuis milliards garantis rien vous
pouvez
se sent blessée ou hulu est malheureux
d'une dune couverte vous pouvez le
reconnaître ça au moins mais comme même
rôle que j'ai
imaginé vous êtes vous non mais je rêve
d'être mari à l'hôpital alors je vous le
dirais tu es malade et que - la spectre
la
peine je m'excuse mais nathalie
j'aimerais que vous compreniez qu'il y
avait rien de malveillant et que c'est
la ligne éditoriale de changer dimanche
et que quand on lit le papier vous
verrez que le papier et au chalut berlin
non mais ça vous a fait de la peine je
veux bien m'excuser je m'en excuse mais
mais changer ni couasnon gers ils vont
acheter au changement d'axé 1 fonctionne
vous le savez très bien vous ne l'avez
pas quitter il la baisse
alors prenez prenez chaque fois je suis
gentil relais mais les spurs et blanc du
nom c'est des conneries mais non mais
parce que vous aimez repris sur internet
mais quand on lit la petite mine en
d'immenses services viennent de sortir
une nouvelle fois débloqué gobelins de
bienveillance qui est là pour aider pour
à pied je me donne à lui
regarder et comprendre la colère
thomas jane
pour les élections c'est truqué j'en
sais pas
[Applaudissements]
mais je t'adore sevmash mais en titre
myriam palombe est une [ __ ] et que
l'arctique est super gentil tenir sur
tpm people ont dit la même chose arrête
an plus tôt
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est l'une des plus grandes voix de la
chanson française
ja c'est à travers un message vidéo
qu'il a bouleversé les français en effet
on vient de me dire les noces ticket une
tumeur au poumon sur les réseaux sociaux
ses plus proches amis de la chanson ont
tenu à lui apporter leur soutien flora
le panier a appris qu'il avait un cancer
des ponts début janvier
mi-janvier c'est
rendue chez un spécialiste à paris avec
sa femme a su sénat pour savoir un peu
quel type de traitement si c'était
opérable si ça ne l'était pas
et puis ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'il
enregistrait les dernières émissions ce
vendredi de devoxx et donc il le savait
quand une en or il avait il savait qu'il
avait un cancer des poumons mais savait
pas voilà de quelle était l'ampleur
quand il enregistrait heureux ici il est
au coin de voile a en fait ce qui s'est
passé que ça ce vendredi-là reçues donc
les résultats du spécialiste qui avait
été voir qu'un jour avant et là bas il
découvre en fait que ce cancer est
inopérable
le téléphone sonne pendant
l'enregistrement
normalement d'arrivée voilà et on
enregistrait en douce et oui et du cou
et du coup ils décrochent et il a il
apprend la mauvaise nouvelle le verdict
tombe le cancer est inopérable voilà
cependant souveraine saperait reprendre
le tournage et reprend le tournage donc
il en parle avec les jurés avec nikos
voilà et puis là tout le soutien c'est
un battant florent pagny et et reprend
il finir l'enregistrement le dernier
enregistrement de des vikes alors là
inopérables pour pour florent c'est à
dire quoi il veut pas pour entrer dans
le cas de florent pagny que je ne
connais pas ici ce qui est important
c'est de dire il faut faire la
différence entre je ne vais pas être
opéré où il est inopérable d'accord
parce qu'il ya des grands cerfs qui ont
une agressivité biologique ou qui
nécessite d'abord des deux refroidi par
des médicaments se veut pas dire qu'ils
sont pas opérables si on avait eu envie
de le faire donc on peut pas suffire
avec les messages qui sont donnés de son
cas particulier je crois que c'est pas
l'objectif voilà donc quand on parle
poumons c'est un des cancers même si on
l'associé à quelque chose de difficile
il ya beaucoup de gens qui en guérissent
d'accord mais le sujet c'est la peur
qu'on a lorsqu'on à ce diagnostic
ça c'est un concert qui se guérit bien
conservée pour ce qui est important
quand quelqu'un apprend son diagnostic
se le faire piquer pas ce qui se passe
chez les autres c'est de savoir si pour
lui c'est pris en charge précocément ça
si le traitement va être efficace et
puis c'est apprendre à gérer finalement
ce qui est difficile l'incertitude ne
rien vous voulez dire clown en mode ce
qu'on m'a dit voilà je sais pas si on
peut révéler un peu le détail mais moi
ce qu'on m'a dit c'est que en fait il
avait une tumeur qui mesurait quand même
5 cm et que
voilà on est assez grave ce qu'on veut
c'est qu'il a acquis ce qu'il s'en sorte
voilà que ça soit pris en chasse
[Musique]
l'émission a dépeint une image bien
sombres de la ville ce qui a suscité de
nombreuses polémiques vous avez manipulé
des gens madame vous en rendez compte ou
pas aujourd'hui l'étudiante musulmane il
ya bouziane qui a participé à une
séquence du reportage dénonce la
manipulation de la production qui
l'aurait contacté pour un reportage sur
la laïcité j'étais comme vous très
surprise de me voir dans ma partage la
future avocate qui s'estime piégé a
décidé de prendre la parole ce soir dans
tpm peut vous imposer quoique en
question alors m'a posé plein de
questions
je viens veillant mais aussi très très
poussé j'ai bien vu qu'on essaie de me
faire dire la phrase qui serait choquant
mais comme je suis droit dans mes bottes
et absolument rien à me reprocher j'ai
parlé tout naturellement et du coup j'ai
en fait j'ai rien dit de plus que ce que
j'avais à dire sur votre plateau gt télé
tous pareils mais malheureusement la
voix off on a coupé certaines phrases à
certains moments même dans le choix de
mes amis ce qu'on sait pas c'est qu'on
m'a filmée sur 48 heures parce qu'on
m'avait vendu un portrait de 20 minutes
donc ça tu es sur 48 heures donc là on
voit que une partie de ma journée on
fait bien attention à montrer qu mais
pour que mes amis qui sont d'origine
maghrébine demande pas des autres alors
que je suis entouré d'amis on avait fait
une soirée on les avait invités on a
fait petite soirée pizza donc il y avait
mes potes des potes juive des potes des
potes protestante catholique a t on
était tout ça est justement c'était
vraiment un message de bienvenue
aujourd'hui sur la journée contre
l'antisémitisme d'ailleurs portant sa
mère alors t'as poussé un coup de gueule
de fou sur les réserves mais vous
imaginez le choc moi j'étais d'un
marchand tranquillement je révisais mes
cours et je reçois plein de sable d'un
stade un coup et je me dis qu'est ce qui
se passe et je vais dans le salon et je
vois ma mère fait regardait
tranquillement comme beaucoup de
français l'émission mais en tachycardie
elle était à l'arrivée plus à respirer
elle avait les larmes aux yeux non elle
m'a dit mais ma fille qu'est ce que tu
fais là qu'est ce que tu fais dans cette
émission elle est aimée mais choqué et
même moi franchement j'ai des vues aux
nettement les mets mes mains je
tremblais tellement j'étais choqué parce
que je m'attendais vraiment pas à ça et
vous savez l'après midi même ça fait
beaucoup de bruit s'était entêté sur
twitter le boycott n'interjette tenté t
il raison ouais et quand j'ai vu ça
on m'avait beaucoup de messages de fans
entourage savais que j'avais enregistrée
par zone interdite on m'a dit mais c'est
pas ton sujet ce soir et moi très naïve
j'ai répondu très sereinement banon sa
part de de roubaix déjà donc je ne suis
même pas dedans parce que dans le
sommaire il va absolument pas mon nom ni
la ville de lyon n'y a ni quoi que ce
soit qui pourrait me concerne et et j'ai
envoyé un message aux deux journalistes
qui vont filmer avant la diffusion et je
leur ai demandé j'ai vu qu'il y avait un
sujet ce soir j'espère que c'est pas moi
vu le sujet je pense pas mais je préfère
ma d'assurer et jusqu'à aujourd'hui j'ai
pas eu de retour et j'ai pas une
nouvelle elles ont bien vu mon coup de
gueule parce que j'ai vu les vues sur
instagram et bien sûr aucune nouvelle
donc à ça prouve la malhonnêteté
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez comprendre
qu'en fait aujourd'hui on est dans une
période où les rapports à l'islam sont
difficiles vous êtes les premiers je
pense à le savoir vous avez
qu'aujourd'hui à des lois qui existent
et je pense que si aujourd'hui ce n'est
interdite vous a contacté de fait sont
déviés c'est un fait représentative de
ce qu'est la société aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on fait passer des lois
séparatiste on dit que ses concurrents
du jour non ces lois séparatistes la f10
l'islam parce qu'il ya un problème
aujourd'hui avec les musulmans en france
d'accord vous via un terreau blême
aujourd'hui
du tout puisqu'il ya la grosse majorité
des français qui considèrent que l'islam
est une menace ni à la république et moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on les laisse parler
déjà ces français donc c'est que ça va
parler de vous d'accord wynn holmes est
d'accord mais j'aimerais bien terminer
oui en disant que si vous êtes mis dans
un documentaire sur le l'espère radicale
de l'islam c'est qu'il ya une bonne
raison que j'ai absolument pas le faire
est musulmane est ce que vous condamnez
en tant qu'intermittent rodage d'anémone
vivez le match on a dit ce qu'on a
enduré par les médias français que
l'émotion il parlait pas mais j'aimerais
bien pression elles répondent année elle
est ce que vous allez adorer les poupées
sur son visage je suis venu pour parler
de deux tubes qui est rien
une poupée servent d'appât de les gens
ont peur de l'islam donc c'est le moment
pour vous devez seulement
condamner sa mélancolie anesthésie on va
dire encore une fois je vais je vais
répondre très simplement à chaque fois
sur les émissions télé qu'on a un
musulman ou une musulmane donc en fait
qu'on est vénale et moi les deux sont
des musulmanes françaises devant devant
de votre ce genre de personne on lui
fait un procès et vous pensez quoi de si
et vous pensez quoi oui c'est important
que jamais de voulez vous on est jamais
su innover ou des vidéos et vous n'y a
pas bien et où il ya beaucoup de
musulmans à qui vous avez victimes des
erreurs tous les musulmans sont déjà
rendus jeudi matin la maison de l'un des
condamnés ont célébré l'entente pas tous
en même temps
j'ai pas regardé le reportage dévoile m
sont inquiets parce qu'il ya des poupées
sans visage c'est ça le problème mais
oui bah oui c'était pas gagné ça
voudrait dire quoi parce que tu es
mal abordé
les et non mais où vous vous taisez vous
sortez jeudi les pistes d'amérique c'est
moi qui donne la parole ici si vous
voulez si on prenez votre bloc-notes et
vous sortez ça fait longtemps que je
n'ai pas énorme et jolie ne vous le dis
on n'est pas là pour ses bons à mardi
pour déterminer si tu es encore une fois
au look la honte à toi du côté des
méthodes qui ont une dent panier mais
reste est désolant de ses documentaires
est-ce que tu qu'on donne tout ce qui
est sûr c'est que j'entends bien votre
coupe bleue et pourquoi pas mais quoi
méditer pied à pied sur sur des sujets
les éléments que vous n'avez pas
visionné santé mais maxime nana mais
qu'on recentrer le débat je suis venu
comprenez vous le coup de gueule de
didier colas et oui voilà mais voilà
c'est mon passage à la question bio
innovation est claire oui mais série
documentaire qu'on était mené au pouvoir
depuis molière
ça ne
vous plait oui puissants n'ont
fait que du direct avec les émissions
depuis lundi les scandales s'enchaînent
à la suite des révélations d'un
journaliste indépendant victor castanet
autour d'une enquête auteur d'une
enquête sur le groupe d'ehpad privé
auprès ans pour en parler ce soir nous
allons recevoir et laterrière une aide
soignante qui avait commencé à dénoncer
ce qu'elle considère être de la
maltraitance institutionnelle depuis
2007 et on aura danny foster directeur
adjoint d pad qui sera avec nous
également pour en parler aujourd'hui nos
aînés sont maltraités dans les ehpad en
france ouais
c'est à dire on leur fait quoi mais on
les aide pas on n'est pas là pour eux on
les abandonne on a l'impression non en
tant que soignant alors que c'est leur
vocation et c'est un métier qu'on a
choisi par vocation et des maltraitances
oui à des maltraitances tel jour pas des
maltraitances physiques parce qu'on
n'est pas là pour frapper nos résidents
on n'est pas là pour ça mais à des
maltraitance institutionnelle quand vous
avez une direction qui vous impose
d'utiliser simplement trois couches par
jour et que vous avez des résidents mais
finalement je vais pas trois fois aux
toilettes dans la journée ça m'arrive
d'aller plus souvent mais si j'ai une
couche et que j'ai au toilette et qu'on
me dit on remet la ta couche parce que
parce qu'on en a pas d'autres je ne me
vois pas remettre une couche salle mais
je pense que personne ici ce revers et
mettre une couche salle quand vous payez
plus de 5000 euros que vous avez
travaillé toute votre vie ou que vous
arrivez à la fin de votre vie vous avez
envie juste de partir paisiblement et
d'apprécier les derniers jours qui vous
reste quand on vous fait
et ça c'est de la maltraitance alors il
ya le journaliste victor castelli autour
du batteur du nil les fossoyeurs qui
dénonce les maltraitances en ehpad il
était l'invité de bfm tv et regardez il
racontait qu'il avait subi des pressions
on lui aurait même proposé des millions
d'euros pour arrêter son enquête
regardez et effectivement il est arrivé
à la moitié de mon enquête pas
directement par le groupe mais via un
intermédiaire qui m'a fait effectivement
une proposition demandant si je serai
prêt à arrêter cette enquête pour pour
15 millions d'euros 1 oui j'aime savoir
que c'est un système qui draine des
milliards d'euros le groupe auquel il
s'est attaqué celle numéro un mondial
est donc pour eux 15 millions c'est une
somme énorme mais pour eux c'est rien
dès que le livre est sorti l'action en
bourse a tellement davis et que la
cotation était interrompue pour eux
c'est une catastrophe est ce un scandale
national cyril c'est un scandale
national c'est bouleversé par sa espère
surtout gilles que ce monsieur ne va pas
maintien qui va arrêter de dire des
conneries qu'il n'est pas venu ici pour
dire des conneries mentir à toute la
france parce que nous il s'agit de nos
aînés de nos parents de nous mêmes plus
tard et arrêter de mentir ans et je sais
pas ce que vous allez dire mais peu
importe la connerie que vous allez
sortir soyez francs battant alors pas
justement danny foster directeur d'un
ehpad bonjour mais qu'est ce que vous
avez à dire d'abord moi j'étais de
soignants avant c'est très bien vous
avez fini directeur c'est pas pour rien
parce que vous aviez mal lorsque vous
faisiez monsieur et que vous avez trouvé
une issue de secours c'est parce qu'elle
trouve être passé mais c'est très bien
pour vous très bien bon en tout cas
évidemment il ya des certains ehpad qui
marche et d'autres qui ne marche pas et
folie donc dénoncé comme vous l'avez
très bien fait mais dénoncée après avoir
été licencié je trouve ça un peu
purement scandaleux si vous avez vu
alors en voir un jour ce parce que j'ai
je n'en mets revoyez vos sources patient
j'ai pas des lancers après avoir été
licencié ceux des nazis afin d'être
aussi parce que j'ai été licencié j'ai
des lancers longs selon le diront pas
des conneries vous êtes après déjà des
conneries monsieur non merci nous a dit
vous êtes après de dire des conneries en
excuser moi aussi si
gros con
connaissions non je ne connais pas mais
c'est un gros combat à partir du moment
où il dit des conneries comme ça
angers vous avez des infos ou rien n'a
changé non mais elle a changé
malheureusement personne ne fait rien
aujourd'hui les gens ils s'alarment
comme si c'était nouveau mais alors
c'est pas vrai on le dénonce depuis des
années et puis ce qui inquiète vraiment
aujourd'hui c'est le fait est que c'est
un ehpad qui coûte super cher ce n est
pas de luxe où c'est jusqu'à 15000 euros
la chambre rôle et c'est parce que les
gens qui sont à l'intérieur ben ils ont
les moyens donc c'est leur fortune
cookies et des mises en question et
c'est là que ça alerte la politique
parce que autant c'est quelqu'un de
quelqu'un du gouvernement karine de ces
parents là dedans et ça les alarmes mais
sinon ils n'ont jamais rien fait madame
on lui dit quoi qu'il arrive que le
patient soit malade ou pas malade ces
trois couches et pas une de plus et peu
importe la situation est donc évidemment
si ces normes et comme ça ils peuvent
pas se débrouiller autrement donc c'est
de la maltraitance oui c'est pour ça que
j'ai répondu nos seniors sont ils en
danger oui il est par ailleurs j'ai
appris que moi que les inspecteurs
d'état quand ils viennent pour vérifier
l'établissement on prévient
l'établissement un an avant on a le
temps de tout mettre en place
c'est totalement faux c'est vrai ça
d'ailleurs mais alors on va laisser le
rythme annuel s'est excusé moi je pense
que vous faites par la direction à ce
que je sache non non si à des contrôles
et je connais certains ehpad qui se sont
fait épingler pour différents motifs
alors arrêtez monsieur quand ça va
arriver à 6 heures du matin mais pas de
larmes 2 en trois ans ils n'ont jamais
mis les pieds à 6 heures du matin dans
un établissement qu'ils arrivent à 6
heures du matin depuis une semaine
qu'ils sont en train de nous de nous
accrocher des règlements par tour des
nouveaux règlements faire attention
qu'on voit comme par miracle qu'on a des
gants qu'on a des couilles qu'on a des
draps et qu'on se rend compte bon c'est
pas ce qui se passait on n'est pas au
courant mais comme par enchantement à
chaque fois deux trois jours après dans
la des inspecteurs qui arrive qu'est ce
qui s'est passé
après le départ des inspecteurs il je
pense que les ehpad que vous décrivez
c'était peut-être je dis peut-être en
2013 ou peut-être avant maintenant ça a
changé quand même nom on a davantage de
soignants est vrai qu'il ya certains
voyant qu'elle or la sérieuse livre
monsieur comme mais alors visiblement
c'est une enquête qui est sur quatre ans
je crois donc comment est ce que vous
étiez récession ce que dans ce même
journal vous l'avez lu le livre de 400
pages vous l'avez vu que j'ai il vient
de sortir donc ce n'est pas pour demain
alors pourquoi on parle des faits
justement si on a lu des extraits mange
un élu vous avez contre 4 me en moi
quelqu'un juste qu'ils évoluent
merci d'être là il ya beaucoup d'eau qui
se posent des questions sur ma personne
parce que j'ai des pays pensent que j'ai
déçus sont dans le coup
sachez le la cij avait eu des suçons
comme ça
c'est la période est derrière avec la
bouche et les classes et géraldine et
tout ça
donc ce ne sont pas des suçons sachez le
même ma mère m'a demandé qu'est ce que
c'est que ces marques rouges fait une
allergie eh bien oui je fais une
allergie aux cons
[Rires]
non pas une allergie
je voulais rentrer des ventouses pour
voilà pour une raison parce que j'ai un
tournoi voilà prochainement très gros
tournois ça nous a leurrés traitement de
sportifs de haut niveau qui n'y est venu
dans les loges humaine que j'adore et
nous voilà et qui m'a mis été mais
dément toute façon exacte ward
éventuellement ça comme ça tout part toi
que c'est un truc de toilette lui
tu crois moi tu m'as débouché
il croise et mes doigts
donc voilà donc ne vous inquiétez pas ça
rien de grave je le dirai même toutes
les 10 minutes pour les gens qui nous
rejoignent qui ont peur et qui posent
des questions sur ma santé n'a pas fait
la même chose vous avez vu des classes
occupent des plus grands sportifs
exactement benzarti losing nathan way
exact en roumanie où ce que j'en vois
qui fait les mêmes les joueurs de nba
et hier soir ils ont fait encore plus
fort avec un fabricant de chaussures
soi-disant transformer en blogueurs mode
et ça a été hyper chaud pour lui dès les
présentations il a failli tout faire
foirer le pauvre voir comment je
m'appelle tristan les
critiques de mode
le johnny depp du pauvre on dirait
johnny blaze
abc d'arcachon d'école non mais ça se
voit que les emplois il reconnaissant
mon cas blement les déguisements
ridicules le le dire que c'est pour un
tournage d'une émission de mode c'est
grotesque et à la fin offrir des
chaussettes à un employé backwash moi
oui c'est ça dépend du mérite mieux que
3 sur 7 violette alors que vous m'avez
jamais rien offert
[Rires]
je trouve vraiment oui est ce que tu as
déjà vu dans une ancienne une grande
enseigne comme ça commercial quelqu'un
qui connaît la toile est pas non plus
yves rocher je travaille chez nocibé
nettoyer la wii donc en fait on leur a
dit que vous alliez bientôt en tournée
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]